the chicago teachers union's causing
chaos and panic for over 350 000
students after pulling the plug on
in-person learning late last night
thousands of families left scrambling
this morning after the union switched
back to remote learning because its
demands weren't met
more than 90 of chicago public school
employees fully vast but that isn't
enough for teachers to do their jobs not
being at school has all sorts of
negative consequences but don't take my
word for it
what we should not be doing
is is allowing ctu leadership to shut
down an entire school system for what
when our district was fully remote
our children suffered
there is no disputing that reality we
should not be politicizing the pandemic
that is a mistake and ultimately hurts
our children and families i believe
schools should remain open
you know
they have what they need
because of the american rescue plan we
provided the states with 130
billion with a b
billion dollars
to specifically keeps our students safe
and schools open the union's demanding
the city spend even more money for a
safer work environment but the city of
chicago already got two billion dollars
in covid funds for schools so what
happened to all the money
and then there's the science you've
heard it over and over again we just
gotta follow it chicago's top doc
blasting the union for not listening
at least among children we have to think
of this as similar to flu you add
vaccination on top of that
the risk is even lower and that is what
we are seeing right now we need kids to
get vaccinated but i remain extremely
comfortable with children continuing
in-person education so geraldo if you
are the mayor of chicago god help us all
what do you do
mayor rivera
well i think that lori lightfoot is
absolutely right jesse this is a
teacher's union ambush i'm generally
pro-union but this this walkout was it
was clumsy it was spiteful it was
absolutely
devastating for these children's
well-being where are they going to eat
some of these families now i think it's
absolutely awful what i would do to
answer your specific question is to dock
them their pay for every day they are
out and i would continue
the lockout the virtual lockout that
lori lightfoot has put in place jessie
she's not letting these absent teachers
sign on to do their virtual education so
they can't say these renegade teachers
cannot say that they presented
themselves for virtual work because
they're not allowed to sign on dock
their pay this is this is absolutely
cruel what they have done to these
children jesse that's a good idea mayor
rivera judge jeanine
the parents relationship with the
teachers has to be destroyed now i mean
it has to be totally destroyed at this
point january 2022. well
look we're in year three of proven what
do we know we know that kids are safest
when they're at school we know because
we talked about it for a long time all
of the danger whether it's psychological
mental whether it's uh just in terms of
emotional and then scholastic all of
them harm to children when they're not
at school domestic violence child
neglect all that we also know that
ninety percent of the teachers are
vaccinated we also know jesse as you
said two billion dollars to protect the
schools now why are teachers saying it's
not safe enough to go to school when
they are in one of the most protected
environments in the country i doubt that
anything is more protected other than a
hospital it's because the teachers are
lazy but ask yourself this for all the
teachers who are afraid to go to school
90 percent of whom are vaccinated among
the least affected of our population
children do they go to dunkin donuts do
they go to the supermarket do they get
into an elevator to go to their
apartment do they get on a bus do they
go to the barber shop are they
separating themselves from society at
large are they just too lazy to go to
work and that's what this is this is an
illegal walkout they should not be paid
and it's time for these teachers to and
they've collected money by the way jesse
for the last three years it's time for
them to not get a paycheck anymore call
it a day and replace them those are all
great points dana where is michelle
obama where's barack obama
jill biden
doctorated education
have you seen enough leadership on the
national level to kind of knock some
heads together in the city of chicago to
get this thing done
uh have you have you checked hawaii that
might be uh one place you could find
them but this i was actually going to
bring this up i think that if biden has
an opportunity here to turn something
around which we're going to talk about
later
if he wants to take it right he said to
them we gave you the money lori
lightfoot is standing there by herself
what i would do if i were joe biden is
tomorrow after i gave my january 6
commentary at the statuary hall at 9am
i'd get on a plane
with uh dr jill biden
with miguel cardona the secretary of
education with javier becerra remember
him the secretary of health and human
services i think he might be in witness
protection for cabinet secretaries using
nowhere to be found during this entire
crisis
and i would go to chicago i would stand
with lori lightfoot i would have
something that says some sort of
concrete thing that says we are going to
have a stand here many democrats across
the country realize just how terrible
this is
and they are worried about it you know
you had nicole hannah jones of the 1619
project saying she said hey we should be
able to talk about how teachers should
be in the classroom
and it goes on from there this is across
the board a terrible situation you know
it's a good thing to think about the
future of
perhaps school choice
being more widely applicable after
something like this but right now you
have a crisis of parents having to try
to homeschool children by zoom while
teachers who should have been vaccinated
but probably
uh will be willing to go to the bar i
mean janine you were very kind asking if
they did all those all those things that
were normal but what a lot of parents
have seen is that some check these
teachers instagram accounts that's all
i'm saying yep great ideas all around
greg let's see if you can contribute
this is you have to look at this from
the positive perspective this is
absolutely great news this is the double
destruction of the pandemic
and of the teachers unions happening at
exactly the same time right we now know
that the pandemic is over the teachers
unions pushed us over the cliff it's
going to happen february 1st where this
is all going to be behind us and it's
time now to sever the ties with the
least competitive entity on the planet
since the washington generals our
education
educational system is just like the
washington generals and that we pay them
to lose the only thing worse is that
they're teaching our children to lose
they're going to lose in life because
they're falling behind we've learned one
really important thing from remote
learning
no one is remotely learning
this
children are locked in supervised jail
time in these schools all that's missing
are three hots and a cot the school is a
prison run by clock watchers and we've
now figured this out this is an amazing
opportunity i think that we should dive
on this it's all about school choice
it's all about introducing competition
into the one place on planet earth
besides cuba and north korea where
competition is seen as obscene it's time
last an msnbc host flipped out on
twitter over a four-year-old not allowed
in a restaurant because the
four-year-old wasn't vast so why would
an msnb anchor get so pissed off about
this because it was his kid it was his
kid so it goes to the gutfeld rule i
mentioned yesterday nothing bad ever
happens until it happens to somebody in
the media and that's what you're seeing
right now with the unions by their
overstepping the looniest of the left
the loonies in left dana mentioned uh
hannah jones uh you have the walking
head head injury known as joe lockhart
you got lightfoot who's about 10 years
behind us in this matter finally
catching up to us so once again you see
that lag but by and now the people that
refuse to listen to us are saying holy
crap it's now my kids it's now my job
it's now my career what the effort we
gonna do well you should have listened
to us because we've been saying this for
two years you stupid morons i have no
sympathy for lori lightfoot she should
have been there at the beginning because
she's a leader but none of these people
are leaders it is time for the american
public to become the leaders to say
we've had enough of this crap it's over
our kids if you're not teaching our kids
we're taking our kids out of the schools
we're not going to pay our damn taxes
either
i didn't think you could top the first
three greg but you did it thanks
congratulations hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else